[Music]
welcome everybody for this panel we are
covering as Max that the very easy
question of what civilization should
strive for so we'll knock that out in
like 30 minutes
right and so I'm joined by Nick Bostrom
of FHI and Amanda a school with open AI
and Joshua green of Harvard and so just
moving on a little bit here again just a
frame it a little bit we're trying to
figure out what civilization should
strive for and so we need to know what
direction we're trying to steer
civilization we need to really know what
it means to align AI systems and what it
means to build something like a post
human ethic for a world which will
likely be inhabited by post human agents
and machines so I think just to start
off like in the workshop and framing
that there was a lot of things the
different value systems seem to agree
upon for what civilization should be
striving for things like trying to get
existential risk to zero spreading
things like abundance widely spreading
knowledge throughout the world
maintaining optionality and you know
better health care and sort of things
which a lot of value systems agree are
just intrinsically good so in terms of
what we can actually do today and action
points that we can do try and figure out
what civilization should strive for and
to set up ourselves for a world where we
can make maximum moral progress what
does our panel think are some of these
these steps we can we can begin with
maybe that's too hard of a question yeah
yeah Josh if you'd like to start you can
go ahead well I think we actually looks
like it has curvy glass buildings with
trees and very quiet vehicles
surrounding them that's what the images
always look like but I I'm you saying
it's a joke but I I think that if you
ask us who are philosophically what's
good and what's
you'll get a lot of different answers
but if you actually sort of lined up all
of the possible futures and asked people
which ones seem like the good ones in
which ones seem like the bad ones at
least among people in this room I think
we'd have pretty good agreement about
that something along the lines of shared
abundance and shared freedom and you
know my guess is that in order to have a
world like that it's going to require a
lot more cooperation and integration
than we have right now so to me the big
question moving forward is how do you
how do you promote that and you know
we've talked about a number of sort of
things to focus on specifically about AI
that is AI safety how do you technically
build machines that are safe or
governance you know policy specifically
for AI but my guess is that what's most
likely to determine our success is not
the things we do specifically about AI
not that we shouldn't be working on
those things as well but about the the
quality of our governance more generally
the way I tend to think about this I
think I kind of acquired my worldview on
these things most directly from from
from Robert Wright in his book in the
late 90s nonzero in which he argued that
you know there's good news and bad news
about the arc of human history that is
good news is that starting with with
with cells to multicellular animals to
small societies to larger societies
there is a path towards greater and
greater complexity and and greater and
greater abundance because there are
gains from trade because we because
there are things that we can do with
teamwork that we can't do as individuals
the bad news is that that cooperation is
always under some kind of strain there's
always some kind of temptation to defect
from within or enemies from from without
and especially at the highest level you
know things evolve because they
out-compete other things but at the
highest level what's going to maintain
competition as opposed to competition
causing whatever structures in place to
break apart so a lot of I guess what
I've been thinking about not
specifically about AI is are there sort
of non-obvious ways that we can build
more cooperative structures and I want
to start with something very small and
then mention historical example that's
very big so when I was growing up my
parents refused to buy German products
especially a German car and that made
sense to me they tried to kill some of
our relatives why would you want to buy
buy buy their stuff
now having thought about this stuff I
think that that's exactly the opposite
that if you want those terrible things
to never happen again
buying the German car is exactly what
you need to do and one of the wisest
things that the United States ever did
was the Marshall Plan where we
essentially collectively as society
decided to do what was not at all
obvious at the time and by the German
car writ large I understand that it was
more complicated than that we were vying
for power with Russia and a lot of other
things and it's not you know such such a
simple story but I think there's some
truth to that understanding of it as a
bold cooperative move and I guess what I
think we need to be thinking about in
addition to things that are specific to
artificial intelligence are what are the
kinds of bold cooperative moves that we
can that we can try to implement with
the abundance that we currently have and
in ways that sort of circumvent the
problems that exist in our current
political process I've been inspired in
part by the economist Paul Romer and his
idea of charter cities where you can
think about one of his insights if it's
right is that in some ways it might be
easier to create something small and try
to grow it that's good that has good
institutions as opposed to taking
something that's already complicated and
messy and in some ways is corrupted and
trying to fix it and I wonder if you
know with the resources that we
currently have there aren't some clever
ways to try to seed good cooperative
institutions and and grow them out in a
way that compete with the problematic
institutes institutions that we already
have and I think that if we figure out
how to scale cooperation from here win
the wrist wisdom race by looking ahead
rather than always having crises that
force us to have to have good ideas and
that's the best way that we're going to
get our brighter future and our
hourglass buildings and trees and quiet
vehicles right and I mean just in
general it's this makes me think that
there's just sort of our
deep questions about what the mechanisms
and principles are like behind
generating good futures like what are
the what are the mechanisms by which
good futures are generated and which are
like principles which are like lead to
negative futures Amanda or Nick you guys
have anything to add here I think on
that question I guess my view would be
that what we're generally trying to do
when we create good futures is identify
things that are robustly good so things
that we just have a lot of evidence will
in fact create good in the world and
wherever they happen to be so like one
thing that worried me a little bit when
I saw the question for this panel was I
thought to myself okay what should the
goal of civilization be how comfortable
would I be with the answer that someone
in like Europe in the 1930s would give
to that question or like how comfortable
would I be with the answer that someone
in like medieval England would give to
that question and I'm like I think the
discomfort there comes from having some
kind of like unified specific goal and
often you know we have those goals but
they change over time as we like
discover new things and so I'd say that
the key thing is to have ways of
identify things in your media
environment that are in fact food you
know so I think that currently we have a
lot of things in that category that we
could like massively improve on in the
short term you know we still have
massive issues like global poverty that
would be really excellent to see like
more work being done in but I also think
that identifying good mechanisms for
finding those kinds of good paths is
like really important and so I think
that one key thing is to embrace both
like discovery and experimentation here
and I think there's like a lot of really
good work starting to be done there and
but we should essentially think of this
as like you know a kind of scientific
endeavor in which we can like find out
more oh yeah right I mean positive
beautiful futures don't come randomly in
the next 30 years they are born because
in each moment every day we choose to do
the right thing or we choose to to make
the world better in some way and so
there's obviously a ton of problems now
and so if we want a positive future
there are a lot of like sort of
obvious and very mundane things that we
can do I think to make it a really great
and beautiful future like for example we
get caught up in all of these beautiful
utopian visions and arguing about
whether or not hedonic consequentialism
is like the best thing ever or the worst
thing ever but we have very like
practical things which we could be doing
now to move ourselves to like much
better futures Nick you know I think the
question what civilization should strive
for is slightly odd in that civilization
is not an agent it's a little bit like
during the Middle Ages people would kind
of impute a D&C at all sorts of
inanimate things you might say the
weather watch the weather strive for to
provide a suitable balance of sunshine
and rain and we can ask the question
what we want or what is good but does
the question what civilization should
strive for and tail anything beside the
answer to those more familiar questions
to the extent that civilization is
something that has agency I guess I
would agree with what Brian said in that
trying to create better cooperative
institutions would be something sensible
if we do compare civilization to an
agent it must be a very mentally ill
agent because different parts of
civilizations are battling other parts
of civilizations it's it's somebody
who's is kind of in a fight with himself
so it's like stopping that would be a
first sense to word sanity yeah so I
think the yeah I'd like to open it up
now to take group discussion there's a
lot of people here that I think have
probably a lot of awesome thoughts about
this so I just like to open up now to
two general questions and then we can
see where the conversation goes el-mahdi
thank you coming back to nick's analogy
with with the mentally ill person back
now what the question is like I don't
know I keep the analogy so that this
mentally ill person would receive some
medication hopefully it works and those
fighting parts
in his brain or her brain will settle
down to an agreement and then he was try
for survival finding a job and being
happy and reproduce etc like I I see
this this can go on like this but like
imagine the mentally mental illness of
civilization was solved is there
something we strive for or no or just
like just go on keep on on what yes you
could ask a general question about what
what is better and what is worse so if
you're asking what ought civilization
morally to strive for if if civilization
were needn't and that would then require
some moral theory to try to specify what
has value or what the obligations of
different actors are I think there are
some distinctive aspects to the question
if if one asks it's in this context that
that may be don't arise so much if one
is thinking about sort of individuals so
the question of so there's like a
smaller scale versions of individuals
but I think I think that kind of look
quite different in this context so you
if we are thinking about the future it
might be that almost all the inhabitants
of the future don't yet haven't yet been
born and so there's the question of
which new kinds of entities to bring
into the world
so population ethics become important
there is the Giants face of different
types of existences like all humans are
kind of the same and then we have
animals that are sort of smaller
versions of humans but digital Minds
like this vast space of weird stuff some
of which could be very good and some
less good so there is the possibility
which is often I feel overlooked in in
in in these kinds of conversations which
is that we tend to think our there's the
human species and we're going to
optimize something and maybe we have to
make sure the AIS we create are treated
well but but it's also possible that we
are not
here right I mean so a that could be
extraterrestrials either within our
future life corner outside that but that
might have an interest in what we do and
we might there might be at other levels
of reality as well like simulators and
such so I think getting into some shape
where a we have cooperative institutions
within our civilization but also then
develop into something that could play a
kind of cooperative responsible role in
this wider scheme of things where we
don't try to create a kind of max greed
AI that you know is willing to ride
roughshod over all the other things but
but something that is more suited for
entering into a much bigger world when
maybe established powers and long
traditions as a kind of citizen that
knows its role I think could be very
important as well I'd like to hear more
from Josh about what you're talking
about
well I guess I've been thinking a lot
I'm not saying this is the answer but
it's just what I've been thinking about
is that economists and historians when
they think about promoting cooperation
they think on a very macro scale and
when psychologists think about
cooperation and conflict resolution they
think on a very micro scale and my guess
is that you need both of those working
at the same time than if you just said
okay Israelis and Palestinians or
liberals and conservatives or whatever
it is come together and have a business
if you're not managing those personal
social relationships well if you're not
thinking about people's emotions if
you're not thinking about people's
identities if you're not thinking about
what is my what is my priest what is my
Imam what is my best friend going to say
about my being here if you're not
thinking about all those softer issues
the whole economic thing is going to
fall apart but if all you think about
are those softer issues you're not going
to solve the problem and not solve the
problem fast enough for it to be useful
so in a in
if I had all the money and power in the
world and I had two groups of people
that I wanted to try to get them to work
well together I would try to structure
something like an enterprise zone or an
ecosystem where you have people engaged
in productive labor but where you have
certain certain rules and expectations
about what the power structures are
likely to be like down to the level of
personnel and when you recruit people
for this you don't just recruit them you
talk to their families you talk to their
to whoever is important to them and in
some sense get their buy-in and get
their blessing and you do this
incremental e so that no one ever has to
take too much of a leap in terms of who
they're working with right and so that's
sort of a rough sketch of I think at
least the aspect of the problem that
I've been thinking about is how do we
think about the macro and the micro at
the same time to bring people together
Oh Wendell differently for the last 300
years which are sort of thought of as
modernity the values were set by you
know 16th and 17th century philosophers
and they put the individual they put
science they put reason at the center of
the collective agenda without having any
idea where that would take them and I
think we're really in a similar
situation we don't truly know what will
unfold an awful lot of what we talk
about is our ideals for Humanity but in
the end we need to come up with values
that reflect what we want to be at the
center of the agenda regardless of how
it's going to unfold or what AGI will or
will not be or how other technologies
will interfere in the process and I
think if we do that it's it's clear from
some of the things that have been set by
the panel particularly Josh and in the
last conversation but also things that
are being discussed at the UN in other
places that some form of cooperative
inclusive
has to be made part of the agenda now
whether that's just added to
enlightenment values or whether the
Enlightenment values are collapsing as
some people have suggested or that they
I really have been truly beneficial
should be continued as Steven Pinker and
others have said I think that's where
the debate lies for us so we need to be
focusing on the values that we want to
inform the next millennia the ethos of
humanity without necessarily presuming
that we know how that can unfold given
those many uncertainties were
confronting yeah great so I think
another oh yeah dick I so you know how
like do a man with a hammer everything
looks like a nail
right I think optimization maybe is our
hammer we have this tendency to like try
to couch things now in terms of the
objective right I mean it's great but
like is this really the right way of
framing I'm just gonna toss you a couple
of quotes henry miller says one one's
destination is never a place but rather
a new way of looking at things or
somewhat more deep perhaps Drake
sometimes it's the journey that teaches
you a lot about the destination you know
I think that these sort of Express maybe
a bit more Eastern thought right it's
it's a bit more Taoist it's more about
each person individually finding their
path right and and when you have a
complex dynamic system like that you've
got a lot of distributed pathfinding
going on and as we know the most
interesting systems like that weave it
it's not necessarily the case that we
can find a neat closed form objective
function to optimize and maybe that is
what is interesting so like I think I
kind of agree with you but I'm maybe
gonna freeze things slightly differently
I think one way to think about these
kinds of questions that we're talking
about here
and or that like what should happen very
long term and then just like aiming at
something that's something that you can
do when you have like a lot of
information about the future paths that
are like available to you and when you
don't have a lot of information about
what those paths look like it's I think
it's much more important to just
identify like next set that are good
given all of your evidence and that will
like hopefully put you in a good
position to identify like further next
steps which are like also good and
giving your evidence and so sometimes
when it sounds like people are talking
about optimization here I don't think
it's with respect to a single goal it's
often with respect to like methods you
know so the things that I will often see
here are just like look reserve option
value like and people who want to do
things like we're jus sick existential
risk or just like make sure that we
don't end up you know with kind of like
bad values that we don't like being kind
of fixed in any way but this is like
what they are expressing I think and
also like you know maximize like
information value as well so like find
out more those things aren't like these
unified single goals so they can look
like it I don't think that we're
catching a falling into this
optimization trap when we talk about
things like the importance of
cooperation that's also just like kind
of a method for getting value and a
method for like discovering new things
and it's the same with like information
value an option values so I like to
think that we're actually thinking more
in the in the kind of incremental way
then maybe that would imply so it sounds
like you're you're thinking more at the
individual agent level resource bounded
optimization it's alright yeah although
I guess like so this applies to
individuals I think what Nick said was
kind of right and that really you have
to think in terms of like agents with
intentions and it's not clear how you
can how you do that over groups for
example if you can I think that many of
these lessons apply to groups as well as
to like individual agents all right so
if you all if you were all to distill
your vision of what civilization could
be striving for or how civilization
should be striving to figure out what
still is a
should be striving for how would you you
distill your vision building bigger
better cooperation preserve options get
information do good stuff
something something along about sly in
the same so so so just to wrap up here
as we're moving towards towards better
and better civilizations we obviously
don't know what we want and we don't
know what we think we should want that
we should want or want you know so so
what are their potential ways in which
we can use AI and leading up until AGI
to sort of leverage this decision-making
process of like determining ox like what
is it that we ought to be striving for
how are ways in which we can use AI or
AGI to amplify human moral
decision-making and human
decision-making and understand human
decision-making with regards to like
value with regards to which world states
are better than others I think we're on
our own for a while
I don't think that we're going to get
much moral help from machines until
we're much farther along yeah I do think
when you have like much more advanced
systems that are like very capable you
want to make sure that those systems can
like or like I think ideally that they
can assist you in like you know showing
blind spots that you have for example so
you know if I have if I can be convinced
that I have a moral blind spot I didn't
think I had I think that's like a really
great thing and I would love something
to assist me in that so I would I would
like such assistance but I think it's
correct that like you wouldn't expect to
have that until like you have pretty
capable system ok I guess I'm not come
fully convinced about the premise which
is that we want to maximize the morality
of our behavior
like who knows man a we don't know what
moral theory is right like some suppose
it's like really unpleasant wanna like
some just desert theory is correct like
that the more the right thing is for
everybody to get what they deserve
could be true right it might be the best
systematization of moral intuitions and
behavior that kind of the simplest
theory that captures a lot of
regularities you know maybe it turns out
that that we have all been quite naughty
and deserve to be punished for that so
the way don't wanna like set up some
system which guarantees that we are
punished forever just so that the moral
the optimal thing happens it might be
that morality is best in moderation that
we want some kind of nudge towards that
but that there are there other things we
care about as well and so optimizing
very hard for morality might result in
radically unpalatable futures and it's
not clear that there would be any humans
there for example I mean you have
hedonism is true you get utility
monsters you get like just a certain
theory you get maybe punishment some
other weird theory we haven't even
thought of who knows what will happen so
I might more lean toward something like
extrapolated relation coherent
extrapolated relation or something like
that alright and with that we have
solved what civilization should strive
for so I'll see you guys in Utopia
[Applause]
[Music]